YOU BOTH.
>> FIGURE I PRAY SHE HAD IT WIT
A SUNSET IN LOS ANGELES IS A GO
CONGRESSWOMAN YOUNG KIM.
WE BROUGHT YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT A YOUNG DIFFERENT ISSUE.
I WANT TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THIS.
THE, LA HARRIS THINK THE BORDER.
PEOPLE FORGET CALIFORNIA IS A
BORDER STATE.
WE ARE NOT SENDING MIGRANTS INT
CITIES LIKE GREG ABBOTT IS DOING
.
BUT IT'S STILL A BORDER STATE
AND FOR VICE PRESIDENT WHO
DECIDES NOT TO VISIT IT SEEMS
LIKE A SLAP IN THE BASIS.
>> A SHAME IN THAT TRAVESTY.
I'VE BEEN CALLING ON THIS
ADMINISTRATION ESPECIALLY THE
BORDER WHO BEEN IN THAT POSITIO
FOR OVER A YEAR AND A HALF HAS
NEVER BEEN DOWN TO THE BORDER T
MEET WITH OUR BORDER PATROL
OFFICERS TO SEE THE CRISIS THAT
I APPLAUD KEVIN FOR RECOGNIZING
THAT AS DEMOCRAT UNHAPPY IN ALL
RECOGNIZING WE DO HAVE A BORDER
CRISIS.
I PERSONALLY HAVE GONE DOWN
THREE TIMES AND I NOTED THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY STRATEGY TO DEAL
WITH THE BORDER CRISIS OF THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
I CAME UP WITH A COMMONSENSE
SOLUTION AND INTRODUCED
COMPREHENSIVE SOUTHERN BORDERS
STRATEGY ACTS SO WE CAN COME OU
MILD BY MODEL STRATEGY.
WE NEED TO HAVE A BETTER CONTRO
OF OUR BORDER.
AND TO NOT GO DOWN THERE OUR
PRESIDENT WHO HAS NEVER BEEN
DOWN TO THE BORDER, I'VE BEEN
DOWN DELI RIO SEPTA THERE IS
CRISIS ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU HAVE
THE LAST 18 MONTHS WE HAVE OVER
150,000 MIGRANTS CROSSING THE
BORDER ON A MONTH-TO-MONTH BASI
FOR 18 MONTHS IN A ROW.
THAT'S A CRISIS OF.
>> IT'S CRAZY IT REALLY IS.
I'VE BEEN DOWN THERE A THOUSAND
TIMES IN OUR REPORTERS ARE
REPORTING THAT PRECISELY WHAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT THERE.
STEVE DOUMBIA.
IF YOU LIKE TODAY THE LOS
ANGELES CITY COUNCIL PRESIDENT
RESIGNED.
FOLLOWING THE STUNNING RELEASE
OF AN AUDIO RECORDING OF RACIST
REMARKS SHE MADE AT A MEETING
WITH FELLOW LATINO
COUNCILMEMBERS LAST YEAR.
MATT THEN IS HERE WITH MORE OF
THE STORY.
>> THIS EVENING THAT FORMER LA
CITY COUNCIL PRESIDENT MARY
MARTINEZ HAS RESIGNED FROM BEIN
PRESIDENT BUT SHE HAS NOT FULLY
PRESENT FROM COUNSEL AND RIGHT
NOW THE LIST OF PEOPLE AND
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE CALLING
FOR THE RESIGNATION OF MARTINEZ
AND THE OTHER TWO COUNCILMEMBER
HAS BEEN GROWING BY THE HOUR.
THERE WILL PROTEST OUTSIDE HAVE
HER HOME TODAY AND TONIGHT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF CALIFORNIA
AND LA MAYOR ERICA GARCETTI
REQUESTED THEY JUST RESIGN.
THE LEAKED RECORDING CAME FROM
REDISTRICTING MEETING LAST YEAR
IN WHICH THE FORMER CITY COUNCI
PRESIDENT IS HARD MAKING RACIST
REMARKS ABOUT THE BEHAVIOR OF A
RIGHT COUNCILMEMBERS A BLACK
CHILD.
[INDESCERNABLE]
>> MARTINEZ ALSO MADE ANOTHER
RACIST COMMENT CALLING THE BLAC
CHILD A SLUR THAT TRANSLATE TO
USE A MONKEY.
TWO OTHER MEMBERS WERE A PART O
THAT MEETING AND ARE ASKED TO
RESIGN FOR APPARENTLY
PARTICIPATING IN SUCH A VILE
CONVERSATION.
IN A STATEMENT IN WHICH SHE
RESIGNED FROM HER POST AS
PRESIDENT, SHE WROTE QUOTE I
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT I
SAID AND THERE ARE NO EXCUSES
FOR THOSE COMMENTS.
I'M SO SORRY.
I SINCERELY APOLOGIZE TO THE
PEOPLE THAT I HURT WITH MY WORD
COLLECTS FAMILIES ESPECIALLY TO
MIKE, SEAN AND YOUR SON.
AS A MOTHER I KNOW I AM BETTER
AND BOB'S SORRY.
I ENJOY THE ASHAMED.
HAVE AT ONE POINT SHE WAS HIRED
AS A POSSIBLE CANDIDATE FOR
MAYOR AND TONIGHT HER PUBLIC
CAREER IS IN FREEFALL.
>> IF YOU WOULD STAND BY BRING
BACK THE CARTER'S WOMAN HERE
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE THAT THIS
CITY COUNCIL I KNOW CITY
COUNCILS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
NONPARTISAN 14 DEMOCRATS AND ON
INDEPENDENT THIS IS DEMOCRATS
ARE FIGHTING DEMOCRATS IN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
>> I CAN SEE THAT.
IN THE WORDS SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES IF PEOPLE ARE
LISTENING TO THIS.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE ELECTION.
THEY CAN HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
AND I AM SO SORRY FOR THE
RESIDENTS LIVING IN LOS ANGELES.
HAD I DON'T REPRESENT LOS
ANGELES BUT I THINK THEY HAVE A
OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP THEIR
ELECTED OFFICIALS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEIR RACIST REMARKS
INSENSITIVE REMARKS.
IT DOES NOT BELONG THERE.
>> IT REALLY DOESN'T.
YOU REPRESENT PARTS OF LOS
ANGELES AND ORANGE COUNTY.
I WANT YOU TO LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS AND PUT THEM ON THE
SCREEN.
MEADOWS HAVE RISEN BY 10 PERCENT
.
AT THAT'S IN THE FIRST QUARTER
OF THE YEAR.
THAT NO RELATED DEATHS IN SEARC
OF 1,262 PERCENT FROM 2016-21
AND A WENCH THIS FISCAL YEAR.
AT THIS IS A COMBINATION OF SOF
ON CRIME AND SOLVED A BORDER.
>> DEFINITELY BECAUSE OF THE
OPEN BORDER THAT WE SEE AND THE
NUMBER OF FENTANYL IN THE DRUGS
IN THAT HUMAN TRAFFICKING THAT
IS OCCURRING AT THE OPEN BORDER
IS WHAT IS CAUSING ALL THESE
CRIMES TO ARISE.
WHAT IS MORE ALARMING IS THE
RISE AND ORGANIZED RETAIL CLIEN
CRIMES.
JUST IN ORANGE COUNTY, IT SEEMS
LIKE EVERY WEEK WE SEE NEWS
ABOUT ANOTHER BUSINESS BEEN
BROKEN INTO.
SMASH AND GRAB ME THEFTS ARE ON
THE RISE HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
LA ORANGE COUNTY.
YET I AM DEALING WITH THAT AND
MY DISTRICT.
THE T-MOBILE STORE AND ORANGE
AND THE TWO JEWELRY STORES AND
MY DISTRICT ALSO DAVID HEYMAN
JEWELERS WAS JUST BROKEN INTO.
IT NOT ONCE BUT TWICE.
I WENT TO VISIT WITH HIM AND HE
IS SHOWING ME THEY ARE NOW USIN
THAT GLASS BUT PLASTIC FOR THE
DISPLAY CASES AND THEY'RE HAVIN
TO REDO AND RETHINK ABOUT HOW
THEY OPERATE.
TO ADDRESS THAT, I HAVE A
SOLUTION COMMON SENSE THAT SAYS
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE A BETTER
COORDINATION AND COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE RETAILERS AND THE
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
>> THE LOCKING THINGS UP IN THE
CABINETS AND THAT'S THE CRAZIES
THING IN THE WORLD.
PEOPLE HAVE TO LITERALLY GO TO
DIFFERENT PEOPLE TO GET
TOOTHPASTE AND EVERYTHING
BECAUSE THEY'RE GETTING RIPPED
OFF DAILY AT THAT'S COSTING
MILLIONS.
>> OUTSIDE AT $6.99 AND NINE
TENTHS AT A $7 A GALLON
CORRECTLY AS WE SPEAK TODAY
$2.50 MORE THAN A NATIONAL
AVERAGE.
THERE IS NOTHING CLOSE AS IT
RELATES TO STATE TAX VAST
MAJORITY OF STATES HAVE GAS
TAXES.
THEY AVERAGE ABOUT 2930 SINCE R
IS ABOUT ABOUT 54.
THIS PRICE GOUGING THEY CAN GET
AWAY WITH AT THEIR PLACING AT
THE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF YOU.
WE HAVE CHECKED AND RECHECKED
THIS.
IT'S NOT TRUE.
>> THAT 54 CENTS PER GALLON THA
HE IS TALKING ABOUT IS BECAUSE
OF HIS AND HIS DEMOCRATIC
LEGISLATOR IN SACRAMENTO.
THEY CREATED THIS WHEN THEY
PASSED THE LARGEST GAS TAX IN
2017.
HAD EVERY JULY FOR THE NEXT TEN
YEARS CALIFORNIANS ARE PAYING
MORE IN GAS ATTACKS BECAUSE OF
THEIR STEAK AZTECS.
THAT'S WHY HAVE BEEN CALLING FO
GOVERNOR FOR MONTHS TO SUSPEND
THAT GAS TAX AND THAT WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO RECOVER RIGHT
UNDERNEATH THEIR AMERICAN SOIL.
IF WE INCREASE OUR DOMESTIC
ENERGY PRODUCTION WEEK CAN KNOW
OUR GAS PRICES.
WHAT HE IS TALKING ABOUT IS
EXACTLY THAT BAD IT FAILED
POLICIES COMING OUT OF
SACRAMENTO.
AS A POLICY THAT CREATED THIS
MESS.
>> IT'S BEEN FACT CHECKED INTO
THESE AT DIFFERENT FUELS AND TH
BLENDS THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE
THAT REFINERIES ESSAY THESE ARE
EXPENSIVE.
WE HAVE TO CHANGE OUT PARTS TO
DO BUT FOR A AND WINTER.
THAT RAISES THE PRICE OF GAS
ESPECIALLY IN CALIFORNIA
DRAMATICALLY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
>> AND WE TALK ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE YOU HAVE DONE THESE
STORIES.
WE KNOW THESE THINGS ARE FACT
KIND WRAP US UP ON THE GAS
CRISIS AND THE GAS PRICES IN
CALIFORNIA.
>> I JUST CAME FROM THE SOUTHER
BORDER IN TEXAS AND GAS WAS
ABOUT 289 WE ARE ALL PLAYING $6
PLUS OUTSIDE OF THE STUDIO.
>> HE DOES BLAME THE OIL
COMPANIES HE INSISTS THEY'RE
FLEECING CALIFORNIANS.
OIL COMPANIES DISAGREE.
>> IT'S AMAZING BECAUSE YOU
THINK WHY WHAT THEY DISAGREE
BECAUSE BY WHAT A NIGHT BY PAT
CARTER BECAUSE EVERY TIME THAT
THE JUDGE OR COURTS HAVE OLD RM
THEY SAID